madame monsieur bonsoir voici les titres
que nous allons développer dans ce 19 20
la ville de toulouse secoué par une très
violente explosion la déflagration
survenue ce matin dans une usine
pétrochimique a fait au moins 15 morts
et plus de 200 blessés toute
l'agglomération toulousaine a ressenti
un immense choc
la guerre des nerfs avec les talibans
devant le congrès de george bush a
promis d' employer tous les moyens pour
écraser les réseaux de terreur l'union
européenne de son côté tient en ce
moment même à bruxelles un sommet
extraordinaire sur le terrorisme les
enquêtes se poursuivent aux etats-unis
en allemagne mais aussi en france avec
un coup de filet ce matin dans les
milieux islamistes
sept personnes ont été interpellées par
la dst en région parisienne et puis une
nouvelle affaire de pédophilie près
d'angoulême m plus une institutrice et
son compagnon ont été mises en examen
le couple est soupçonné d'avoir commis
des viols et des agressions sexuelles
sur plusieurs élèves de maternelle ce
matin donc vers 10h15 les habitants de
toulouse ont bien cru vivre le tragique
scénario de new york et washington
une très violente explosion a secoué la
ville selon toute vraisemblance il ne
s'agit pas d'un attentat mais d'un
accident survenu dans une usine
pétrochimique implantée à la périphérie
le bilan néanmoins est extrêmement lourd
quinze personnes ont été tuées et 50
autres grièvement blessés une
déflagration qui a causé vous allez le
voir de très importants dégâts
jennifer albert's
des images de guerre un site entièrement
dévastés c'est tout ce qu'il reste de
l'usiné azf de toulouse
peu avant 10h30 ce matin une violente
explosion secoue la ville rose
elle vient de souffler l'ancienne
poudrerie près de 400 salariés sont
immédiatement je pense pas vous étiez
vous j'étais au travail travail la
semvat suite à ce vote
et vous monsieur excisées mage et il
avait moi une vraie demain bureaux
commence à s'écrouler le que je vais en
est sorti le plus limité possible mais
bon c'est bon je vende première fois que
je que j'évite ça on a eu une explosion
on sait tous qu'on pouvait dans l'état
où on est là je ne peux pas vous en dire
plus pour l'instant
donc notre première priorité c'est de
d'évacuer baissé et ils sont des
centaines temps 50 gravement touché
l'explosion souffle toutes les vitres
dans un rayon de quatre kilomètres
la préfecture demande aux habitants de
rester chez eux le centre de toulouse et
même évacuer un nuage chimiques en
provenance de lusine se dirige vers la
ville un périmètre de sécurité de 30 km
est mis en place sur la rocade situé à
quelques mètres du sinistre
on se demande ce qui a bien pu se passer
là-bas
voilà ma fille est une vision garder la
maîtrise incroyable de coups comme ça
après plusieurs heures d'inquiétude les
autorités rassurent enfin la population
le nuage chimique n'est pas toxique le
périmètre de sécurité donc levé en
milieu d'après midi mais le plan rouge
reste en place je vous rappelle le bilan
encore provisoire 15 morts et 240
blessés c'est le plan rouge a
immédiatement été déclenchée
trois hôpitaux militaires à bordeaux
lyon et paris ont même été mises en
alerte à toulouse et ses environs tous
les hôpitaux ont été immédiatement
submergé par l'arrivée des victimes et
notamment des victimes
deux des incendies des grands brûlés des
hôpitaux de campagne ont donc été
installés près du site où se sont rendus
jacques chirac et lionel jospin sur
place le reportage de nikon le onal
démocrature à nous sommes à 1 km environ
à vol d'oiseau du lieu de l'explosion
et c'est ici à la croix de pierre qu'à
véritable hôpital de campagne a été
installé dans un centre de rééducation
des invalides civils
un centre tri d'assaut par des centaines
de blessés c'est les premiers soins le
promu pays soit dirigé savoir s'il faut
on a envoyé du côté un hôpital ou sinon
les gardes et d'ordonner les petits
soins et leur envoyer chez
éventuellement pour essayer de soigner
les plus gros surtout plat on va avoir
maintenant les oublis qui vont arriver
là dans la salle d'attenté improvisé en
plein air les blessés se succèdent à
gare nous nous étions près de la sortie
c'était le premier bâtiment de près de
la sortie et qui s'est effondré
également on a peut être eu la chance
d'avoir une structure métallique qui
souffle on s est retrouvés sous les
bureaux autres pendant est sorti par
miracle pour moi ça va
merci aux actes voilà je vais couper
qu'ils sont
nous sommes des jeunes qui ont de la
chance nous sommes l'escap et vous allez
l'avoir côtoyé chez canon maison et puis
après ces blessés sont soignés par des
médecins des infirmiers des sapeurs
pompiers venus de tout midi pyrénées
mais aussi de tout le grand sud ouest
énormément de blessures légères coupures
multiples et par contre après il ya des
blessures beaucoup plus lourdes avec
des traumatismes multiples fémur
colonnes
c'est une cure scapulaire thorax en
début d'après midi
lionel jospin est venue sur place pour
remercier le personnel médical et
soutenir les blessés j'ai été
terriblement impressionné par par les
dévastations que j'ai aperçu sur le site
y compris comme nous sommes passés sur
la rocade
naturellement je pense d'abord à tous
ceux qui sont victimes déjà dont nous
savons que le nombre est significatif et
puis après nous avons voulu être auprès
des blessés de ceux qui sont touchés
choquer pour pour leur dire que nous
sommes avec nous les entourons vers 16
heures c'est le président de la
république qui est venu réconforter les
uns et les autres je ressens comme
toujours en cas de drame une très grande
peine une très grande émotion
on a vraiment l'impression qu'on est
personnellement touchée quand on voit
ces hommes ces femmes ces jeunes qui
sont blessés légèrement tant mieux et là
on a le sourire
où est la seule plus gravement et là on
se sent forcément personnellement
touchés comme le remarque et tout à
l'heure le maire de toulouse
et tandis que jacques chirac s'éloigne
des voisins des collègues des familles
essaient de retrouver les leurs la
déflagration très violente donc été
ressenti dans toute la ville et il faut
dire que la secousse provoquée par
l'explosion et qui va l'être à un séisme
d'une magnitude de 3,4 sur l'échelle
ouverte de richter une intensité relevé
par l'institut physique du globe de
strasbourg toute l'agglomération
toulousaine a donc été secoué par l'ondé
de choc ce fut le cas notamment dans le
quartier du mirail où vivent 25 mille
personnes et où les dégâts là aussi sont
très importants le reportage de vincent
albinet et jean lépine y à quelques
centaines de mètres seulement de l'usiné
azf les premiers immeubles du mirail
sont pas remis de ses fiches et des
cloisons éventrait des vitres explosées
des meubles renversés des fuites d'eau
comme chez la famille hamadi qui se sont
livrés je sais même pas où est ce qu'on
va dormir aujourd'hui juge
on peut même pas sortir de chez nous on
est obligé de rester parce qu'elle est
les trucs toxique quand on voit ça on
n'a même plus envie de rester à la
maison là on a tous moi j'ai plus envie
de rester sûrement la gg +1 vg j'ai
voulu rester dans cette maison au mirail
25000 habitants une ville dans la ville
passés les premiers moments de
stupéfaction
on a dû s'organiser dans l'urgence entre
voisins y compris pour sortir les
personnes bloqués dans les ascenseurs
aux personnes étaient descendues
récupère la trappe en eau
le secours et l'a fait sortir la rom ont
intérêt à bloquer une corde ont
l'intention de leur faire remonter cinq
ans pendant ce temps là dans les écoles
du quartier ont géré comme on pouvait
cette situation de crise avec l'école
d'à côté on s'est confié au personnel de
la radio la faute les enfants les écoles
leur forme j'aurais tant qu enfant donc
sur sa presque
merci écoles fermées logement sinistré
commerces détruits
il faudra du temps pour évaluer réparer
les dégâts matériels subis par une
population en état de choc et tout de
suite après l'explosion les habitants
ont été priés de se calfeutrer chez eux
à cause d'un nuage toxique dont le
danger n'était pas encore évalué ce soir
les mesures de sécurité ont été levés
mais toute la journée dans les écoles
les entreprises également à l'aéroport
bref dans toulouse et ses environs la
vie quotidienne a été fortement
perturbée même si les toulousains ont
gardé leur calme
l'usiné pétrochimique souffler ce matin
par l explosion fait partie des 400
sites industriels français qui présente
des risques importants pour
l'environnement qui a bien sûr
d'accident ces sites à haut risque
soumis à une législation très stricte
sont classés seveso seveso du nom de la
catastrophe survenue en italie il ya 25
ans les explications de dominique
d'humains la peur de la toxicité du
risque chimique a commencé ici en
juillet 76 dans le nord de l'italie à
seveso une usine d'herbicides explose
libérant dans l'ère des tonnes de
dioxyde un an plus tard la france prend
les premières mesures de prévention mais
il faudra attendre 1982 pour la première
directive seveso 372 sites sont alors
concernés depuis février 99 cette
directive est renforcée à plusieurs
reprises et 600 enquêtes ont été
réalisées
et dans les sites seveso premier
objectif évaluer les dangers et préparer
avec les autorités les plan d'opération
interne et les plans particuliers
d'intervention
autre point important les périmètres de
sécurité avec une urbanisation réduite
et l'information obligatoire des
riverains difficile d'adapter ce point
important lorsque les installations sont
anciennes et antérieures comme à
toulouse au premier décret de 70 par
exemple ici en normandie les habitants
estiment lusine beaucoup trop proche de
leur habitation d'origine
bonjour je voudrais les premiers puis on
peut toucher parce que j'ai de la
famille qui habite à toulouse juste à
côté
et puis bah ça peut arriver ici parce
qu'on a une maison qui me paraît juste à
côté là parce que ce produit roja lui à
toulouse ça nous fait penser encore plus
pour nous tous ces gens là mais nous on
est très très très proches
on est toujours dans le dans les fumées
dans les brouillards comment atrous
d'ailleurs autre point comment éviter de
réaction en chaîne entre une usine en
feu et d'autres sites à risques c'est
l'effet domino des simulations
d'incidents grandeur nature sont
réalisés comme ici dans la région
grenobloise des simulations qui ne
rassure pas forcément les riverains et
on direct du site théâtre ce matin de
cette dramatique explosion nous
retrouvons au côté du maire de toulouse
philippe douste-blazy notre
correspondant marque de glee marque le
bilan vient encore de s'alourdir
oui on parle on parle maintenant d'une
vingtaine de morts et de plus de 230
blessés je suis à côté vous le disiez du
député maire de toulouse philippe
douste-blazy dans la première question
où étiez vous comment avez vous vécu ce
qui s'est passé ce matin j'étais comme
le toulousain au travail j'étais à mon
bureau
tout le monde a cru que l'explosion
avait lieu dans sa cave ou dans son
grenier ou même dans la pièce à côté
tellement cet effort la raison pour
laquelle nous avons voulu à la mairie de
toulouse bon bien sûr je suis venu tout
de suite mais au delà me demander aux
psychiatres ou psychologues de venir et
nous avons vraiment mis tout de suite un
soutien psychologique parce qu'il ya des
enfants
il y a des des adolescents il y avait un
adolescent qui est mort dans un lycée 1
km2
si tellement le souffle a été fort et
donc il ya des gens ici qui sont très
touchés il faut qu'ils parlent et nous
avons là je veux dire vraiment que les
médecins ont répondu de manière
extraordinaire les toulousains ont été
très courageux
on le savait mais là ils l'ont prouvé
avec beaucoup de dignité
les pompiers les infirmières nous avons
fait monsieur est un tri médical pour
prendre les plus touchés ce qui devait
être amputée ce qui devait avoir des
choix immédiatement être opéré et puis à
te faire attendre les autres et
aujourd'hui vraiment au moment où nous
parlons il ya plus de 300 blessés quand
été soignés dans les hôpitaux
toulousains et les plus fugaces dix
joueurs toulousains et plusieurs
associations qui ont déjà dénoncé la
présence de cette entreprise ici vous
même d'ailleurs aussi oui je les fais
bien sûr que nous parlerons de cela
après pour le moment l'heure est au
deuil au recueillement
et puis surtout à à l'urgence parce que
il y a encore des gens que l'on sort de
ces décombres qui sont à côté de nous
qui vont arriver dans les hôpitaux
très rapidement nous avons mis en place
un numéro de téléphone à l'amérique et
le 05 61 22 21 43 qui permet à tous les
toulousains de savoir ce qui se passe
d'être rassurés de pouvoir avoir un
soutien psychologique et aussi il ya des
milliers de toulousains ce soir qui
n'ont pas d'habitation qui n'ont pas de
logement parce qu'ils ont été soufflées
et bien nous avons mis en place des
gymnases nous avons mis en place des
centres d'hébergement pour qu'il puisse
y avoir pour un lit un repas et un
soutien psychologique
fillon qui a dépassé pardonnez moi et
même si ça dure plusieurs nuits
philippe douste-blazy une enquête a donc
été ouverte est ce que ce soir on peut
totalement exclure l'hypothèse d'un
attentat que beaucoup on redoutait ce
matin savez ça s'est passé dans un lieu
de stockage un lieu de stockage de
nitrate
c'est un lieu où il n'y avait pas
spécialement de manipulation personne ne
sait aujourd'hui c'est cet accident ou
autre chose
les policiers ont commencé leur enquête
il faut leur faire confiance
il faut que la transparence soit faite
aussi sur cela il faudra dire exactement
ce qui s'est passé en tout cas pardon
moi je vais être obligé de repartir à
l'hôpital là maintenant pour pourvoir
est une chaîne de solidarité formidable
qui est fait et je veux évidemment avec
les toulousains participation merci
philippe douste-blazy d'avoir été en
direct avec nous pour le 19/20 voilà
donc ce que nous pouvions dire ce soir
concernant cette dramatique explosion
dont je vous rappelle le dernier bilan
au moins 18 morts et plusieurs centaines
de blessés
si vous souhaitez obtenir des
informations supplémentaires vous pouvez
appeler la mairie philippe douste-blazy
vous a donné le numéro mais également le
numéro d'urgence de la préfecture c'est
le 08 11 00 06 31
vous pouvez aussi vous connecter sur le
site internet www.francesoir.fr toulouse
l'autre grands titres de l'actualité
c'est bien sûr la suite des attentats
aux états unis partout dans le monde des
enquêtes se poursuivent pour tenter de
démanteler les réseaux terroristes liés
bien sûr à oussama ben laden
tôt ce matin un coup de fil a été
effectuée en région parisienne sept
personnes soupçonnées d'appartenir aux
milieux islamistes ont été interpellés
ces arrestations interviennent dans le
cadre de l' enquête sur une menace
d'attentât contre l'ambassade américaine
à paris et les galants comme ici à
bezons les perquisitions se sont
déroulées en région parisienne peu après
minuit et pour certaines familles qui
préfère garder l'anonymat
la présence de la dst chez elles la nuit
dernière est incompréhensible
on est une famille calme lui il est là
depuis 1995 il s'est bien intégré dans
ce cas là pourquoi il va travailler de 8
heures de 8 heures du matin jusqu'à 5
heures de l'après midi pour gagner son
gagne pain
sept personnes hommes et femmes français
algériens et français d'origine
algérienne sont en garde à vue dans les
locaux parisiens de la direction de la
surveillance du territoire ce soir des
disquettes et des cassettes vidéo ont
été saisis
une huitième personne est en fuite ces
arrestations ont été précipités après la
diffusion
des révélations faites par djamel beghal
ce franco algérien considéré comme un
proche d'oussama ben laden est
actuellement détenu aux émirats arabes
unis
c'est lui qui a informé les enquêteurs
du projet d'attentât à la voiture
suicide contre l'ambassade américaine à
paris ces déclarations avaient déjà
provoqué des arrestations la semaine
dernière aux pays bas et en belgique à
bruxelles précisément les policiers ont
interpellé mizar trabelsi chez ce
tunisien ancien footballeur
professionnel
ils ont trouvé deux fusils mitrailleurs
et des documents comportant des formules
chimiques
aujourd'hui ils viennent de découvrir
dans le café ou nizar trabelsi avait ses
habitudes de fortes quantités de soufre
et une dizaine de litres d'acétone des
produits parfois utilisé pour fabriquer
des bombes artisanales
en france ce sont les juge
antiterroriste jean louis bruguière et
jean françois ricard qui sont en charge
de ce dossier un dossier aux
ramifications européenne est justement
la piste allemande connaît de nouveaux
développements le parquet fédéral vient
de lancer deux mandats d'arrêt
internationaux contre un homme de 29 ans
de nationalité yéménite et un allemand
d'origine marocaine âgé lui de 26 ans
ils sont soupçonnés d'avoir participé à
la préparation des attentats de new york
et washington
les deux suspects vivait dans le même
appartement que mohammed atta l'un des
kamikazes et comme lui il était étudiant
à hambourg
hier soir à washington c'est devant un
congrès réuni au grand complet que
george bush a de nouveau promis à ses
concitoyens
la victoire sur les terroristes et il a
également demandé aux gouvernements du
monde entier de choisir leur camp une
nouvelle fois le président américain a
lancé un ultimatum aux talibans afghans
nora boubetra
andy nightster jamais le président bush
n'aura été aussi populaire avant même le
début du discours l'auditoire est courte
il est 21h heure locale le chef de la
maison blanche s'apprête à délivrer son
plus grand discours lui qui d'habitude
n'est pas connu pour ses talents
oratoires vient d'entrer dans l'histoire
pendant quarante minutes il s'est
adressé au congrès et des barrières se
font dès hier soir il n'y avait plus ni
républicain ni démocrate
juste des américains que nous amenions
nos ennemis à la justice qui nous
amenions la justice à nos ennemis
cherchent juste il sera fait
hachette déclaration une nouvelle salle
debout dans l'hémicycle il ya des mêmes
là le premier ministre britannique à qui
georges bush a rendu hommage à tony
blair qui ne s'est certainement jamais
senti aussi proche des américains
mes chers compatriotes ces neuf derniers
jours le monde entier a constaté qu'elle
était l'état d'esprit de notre nation et
il est soliste en un message de
confiance et aussi un message de fermeté
le chef de la maison blanche a une
nouvelle fois demandé aux militaires de
se tenir prêts
il n'a annoncé aucune opération ni aucun
calendrier
seule information que sarah une guerre
de longue haleine sans commune mesure
avec les précédents quoi puis mené par
les états unis en gagnant toutes les
preuves convergent dans le réseau
al-qaïda dirigé par ben laden at il dit
avant de lancer cet ultime avertissement
aux talibans ce soir nous exigeons des
talibans qu'ils nous livrent
immédiatement les chefs d'al-qaïda
cachés dans leur pays
or ces demandes ne sont pas ouvertes à
la négociation ou à la discussion
les talibans doivent agir et agir
immédiatement livrons les terroristes ou
bien faut-il chantage ont leur sort
george bush a également montré à l'asim
où il tenait dans sa main
celui d'un policier mort alors qu'il
tentait de sauver des jfc sa mère marie
line qui me l'a donnée ces prêts à
recommencer ma façon de me souvenir des
vies qui ont été perdues et d'une tâche
qui ne finit pas d'âge narines comment
elle aurait dit
devant tant d'émotions selon les
derniers sondages 91 pour cent des
américains soutiennent leur président
c'est également le meilleur audimat
enregistré par une intervention
présidentielle
ces dix dernières années dix jours après
les attaques terroristes les recherches
ne sont toujours pas officiellement
stoppées même s'il n'ya pratiquement
plus aucun espoir maintenant de
retrouver des survivants
le bilan des victimes s'est brutalement
alourdi avec l'annnonce de 911 nouveau
disparu dans les décombres du world
trade center
entre new york et washington le nombre
total de morts ou de disparus s'élève
donc désormais à 6807 plus de 6000
personnes ont été blessées dans le même
temps le mouvement des forces
américaines se poursuit plusieurs
navires de l'us navy ont appareillé pour
la méditerranée et le golfe
le destroyer cutting s'apprête à
rejoindre le porte-avions kitty hawk qui
lui a quitté la base de yokosuka au
japon direction l'océan indien et en
caroline du nord lé premier détachement
de marines viennent de partir 2200
hommes qui se sont embarqués pour une
destination tenue secrète en
méditerranée cette opération était
prévue de longue date mais elle prend
bien sûr une dimension toute
particulière au moment de l'organisation
de la riposte militaire sur place le
reportage de jean marc pitte et pierre
dick
camp lejeune la deuxième plus grande
base du corps des marines aux etats unis
plus de 40 mille soldats sur un
territoire grand comme manhattan
deux mille deux cents d'entre eux
partent vers une destination tenue
secrète en méditerranée pour une mission
de six mois prévu de longue date mais
qui après les attentats prend un sens
particulier
je ne sais pas où il va je me sens plus
déprimés plus effrayé avoir à vivre seul
sans lui pendant six mois au plus c'est
très dur
il s'est déjà retrouvé dans ces
situations il sait comment les gérer et
il est toujours rentré à la maison
il rentrera cette fois aussi non alors
non je ne parlerai pas de vengeance mais
quand tu commets un crime
tu dois le pays
les officiers préfère parler d'
opération de routine pour laquelle leurs
hommes se sont entraînés depuis
plusieurs mois mais ils savent aussi que
la vague de patriotisme qui a déferlé
sur le pays depuis des attentats ne peut
laisser froids leur sommes les premiers
à partir en expédition mariné ou des
rêves de vengeance ce sont leurs rêves
personnels
nous sommes des professionnels nous
devons nous comporter comme des
professionnels de chacun ressenti des
émotions particulières après les récents
événements on ne peut pas le nier mais
nous sommes des pros et nous devons agir
en conséquence
mais à bord des trois vaisseaux prêt à
quitter le port de murray head pour les
emmener en mission la colère s'exprime
librement partir parce que j'éprouve une
énorme injustice
j'espère aller en afghanistan pour tuer
ceux qui doivent être cuites et pour
retrouver la fierté que nous avons perdu
le président george bush avait promis
une réponse rapide
le départ de ces hommes en constitue le
premier élément c'est d'abord un signe
fort envoyé à l'opinion publique
américaine
c'est ensuite la confirmation que
l'option militaire reste la plus
probable et de l'autre côté du monde
pour la cinquième journée consécutive le
pakistan a été le théâtre de nombreuses
manifestations anti-américaines
l'éffigie du président bush a même été
brûlé plusieurs milliers de personnes
ont une nouvelle fois protester contre
l'éventuelle riposte américaine mais
aussi la collaboration des autorités
pakistanaises sur place le reportage de
nos envoyés spéciaux au pakistan donc où
la situation est de plus en plus
explosive
régis nussbaum stéphane taponier
la journée s'annonçait particulièrement
tendu
on craignait des débordements et les
violences un vendredi jour de grande
prière pour les musulmans
les autorités pakistanaises ont tout
juste toléré la manifestation la police
est relativement discrète les boutiques
encore ouvertes baissent leur rideau
ils sont plusieurs milliers à défiler
dans les rues de la vieille ville de
peshawar
parmi les slogans nous sommes tous des
talibans nous sommes tous les oulamas
ben laden
oussama ben laden est notre hôte
et s'il souhaite partir de lui même il
peut le faire mais aucun afghan ne peut
le forcer à quitter le pays
l'islam est dit qu aucun musulman ne
peut être livré un non musulman non
seulement un soleil au couple dassa les
autres il
le mollah omar chef suprême des talibans
n'a pas encore décidé du sort d'oussama
ben laden
en attendant les islamistes refuse toute
idée de coopération militaire avec les
états unis si ça arrive on va faire la
grève
on va manifester on va combattre votre
guide contre la mairie avec des armes
nous on n'a pas d'âme
notre cela c'est à la d'autres
rassemblements ont eu lieu dans les
grandes villes du pakistan comme ici à
karachi au sud du pays
karachi où les manifestations dégénérer
les islamistes se sont heurtés aux
forces de police
il y aurait au moins quatre morts d'une
certain prié par balles et plusieurs
blessés ce sont les premiers morts
pakistanais depuis que le président
musharraf a décidé d'apporter son
soutien aux états unis et à peshawar
nous retrouvons régis nussbaum une
rumeur se fait de plus en plus
insistantes le suspect numéro un oussama
ben laden aurait quitté l'afghanistan
l'information a été donnée ce matin par
deux news l'un des principaux quotidiens
pakistanais et selon ce journal oussama
ben laden aurait quitté l'afghanistan il
y a quatre jours en compagnie d'une
partie de ces mercenaires arabes le
milliardaire saoudien serait parti vers
le liban ou vers la tchétchénie de pays
qui vous le savez n'ont aucune frontière
commune avec l'afghanistan alors
difficile dans ces conditions d'accorder
du crédit à cette information
sauf qu'elle provient du général babar
l'ancien ministre pakistanais de
l'intérieur c'est lui qui avait parrainé
le mouvement des talibans à ses débuts
en 1994 la formation est bien sûr
impossible à vérifier
elle n'a en tout cas pas été confirmée
par les talibans les talibans qui se
refuse toujours à livrer oussama ben
laden aux états unis fréchistes us comme
au pakistan une situation internationale
qui inquiète bien sûr l'union européenne
les chefs d'état et de gouvernement des
15 sont actuellement réunis à bruxelles
pour un sommet extraordinaire une
réunion convoquée dans l'urgence avec
bien sûr pour thème la réponse au
terrorisme mais aussi la solidarité
envers les états unis françois paul et
mathis et 15 chefs d'état et de
gouvernement ont voulu ce sommet
européen extraordinaire tout d'abord
pour marquer leur solidarité entière
avec les états unis
solidarité dans la condamnation bien sûr
mais aussi dans le souhait d'une riposte
adaptée et efficace mais le message des
15 c'est surtout de données en europe
même un coup d'accélérateur décisif à la
lutte anti-terroriste donner les
instructions pour que le mandat d'arrêt
européen soit effectif dans les mois qui
viennent renforcer les échanges de
renseignements ne put s'opposer au
transfert de suspects d'un pays à
l'autre
renforcer les moyens d'europol en
spécialisant les équipes antiterroriste
piste et enfin et démanteler les
circuits financiers qui nourrissent ce
terrorisme
la tragédie du 11 septembre en fait
provoqué un choc tel en europe
aujourd'hui les états européens
admettent qu'il est urgent en matière de
lutte antiterroriste de mettre un petit
peu de côté qui est égoïsmes nationaux
merci françois paul et les matisse dans
le monde entier les marchés financiers
ont vécu une folle journée marquant la
fin d'une semaine tout aussi agité on
est passé très près du crack tous les
indices ayant fortement chuté mais ce
soir sur les places financières et
notamment la bourse de paris et la
situation s'est redressée
martine l'ex robin des bois la courbe du
cac40 ce matin
'l'indice des meilleurs titres français
s'est effondré allant jusqu'à perdre
plus de 7% de sa valeur
un vrai plongeon épilogue d'une semaine
agitée où la bourse de paris n'a pas
cessé de baisser
dans le même temps les marchés européens
et asiatiques cédaient à la même panique
à tokyo le nikkei perdait 2,4 pour cent
londres et genève 5 % dans l'affolement
général en fin de matinée les financiers
n'hésite pas à parler de krach
on est sur une configuration de krach
boursier l'heure actuelle de sachant que
si on se compare aux niveaux qui
prévalaient sur le cac40 depuis
septembre 2000 où s'harmonisent sur une
baisse d'environ 48 % donc par
comparaison lors du krach d'octobre 87
au plus fort de la baisse on avait une
diminution de 37 %
finalement l'éclaircie viendra de wall
street à l'ouverture la bourse de new
york limite les dégâts avec un dow jones
en légère baisse
du coup les bourses européennes se
redressent et à la clôture le cac 40 ne
perd plus que 2,28 % mais les marchés
restent nerveux
la crainte d'une récession mondiale
incertitudes sur la riposte américaine
autant d'inquiétudes pour les
investisseurs
même si les économistes restent prudents
comme aujourd'hui il y a urgence pour
que les autorités politiques fassent le
nécessaire pour éviter une victoire
totale que ring
construit dans la sphère économique je
n'ai pas beaucoup de crainte que ce
krach me suscite des conséquences
économiques des palois aujourd'hui les
marchés ont fini par se ressaisir mais
les financiers font le dos rond
d'autant qu'à la bourse de new york le
dow jones n'arrête pas de futur une
nouvelle affaire de pédophilie près
d'angoulême je vous le disais dans les
titres une institutrice de ruffec et son
compagnon ont été mises en examen
ils sont soupçonnés d'avoir commis des
viols et des agressions sexuelles sur
plusieurs élèves de maternelle en 95 le
couple avait déjà fait l'objet d'une
enquête mais à l'époque plus le dossier
avait été classé sans suite
nathalie cause déjà soupçonné de
pédophilie lille 6 ans une institutrice
de cette école et son compagnon viennent
d'être écroué pour viol au moins trois
élèves de la maternelle de ruffec près
d'angoulême aurait été victime du couple
des enfants âgés de trois à quatre ans
ce sont des parents troublée par le
comportement de leurs enfants qui en
donne l alerte
ça a commencé par un dessin
et puis c'est quoi elle s'est confiée à
sa tante
j'étais là j'étais pas trop loin j'ai
tout entendu ce qu'elle a dit
l'institutrice et son compagnon un
gendarme à la retraite aurait attiré les
enfants chez eux dans leur maison juste
à côté de l'école en 95 déjà le couple
est placé en garde à vue pour des faits
similaires l'enquêté est alors classé
sans suite
le maire de ruffec c'est pourtant posé
une grille entre l'école et leurs
maisons une grille qui aurait été coupé
par l'institutrice
ça aurait dû être plus surveillées
tournon qu'il y avait déjà eu dans
certains années passées des suspicions
réelle ou pas on ne sait pas on ne peut
pas savoir
mais ça aurait dû être plus surveillées
et vraiment surveiller cette
institutrice suite aux plaintes déposées
la semaine dernière par des parents les
gendarmes ont ouvert une nouvelle
enquête
les témoignages des enfants seraient
accablants pour l'institutrice et son
compagnon
les témoignages qu'il conteste d'une
part de parler l'âge l'âge des prêtres
des prétendus en tout cas des présumées
victimes trois quatre ans on peut
estimer que leur audition ou en tout cas
leur comportement ou les gestes qu'ils
ont pu avoir vis-à-vis des psychologues
et bien peu de choses ces
interprétations et en tout cas il faut
je crois avoir de prendre de grandes
précautions
une équipe de psychologues a été mise en
place pour prendre en charge les enfants
et soutenir leurs parents et dans cette
actualité particulièrement dramatique
une image beaucoup plus légère et
souriante à rotterdam aux pays bas
l'équipe de france de tennis est bien
parti pour se qualifier pour la finale
de la coupe davis
les joueurs de qui dit forget elle-même
poussoir deux victoires à zéro face à
arnaud clément
et nicolas escudé puisque idée a dû
batailler cinq sets et près de cinq
heures de jeu pour donner l'avantagé à
la france 2 0 donc face aux pays-bas le
double aura lieu demain par ailleurs en
basket l'équipe de france féminine s'est
qualifiée pour les demi finales de
l'euro en battant à tout à l'heure la
slovaquie 72 à 56 je vous rappelle donc
la principale information que nous avons
développées dans ce 19 20 la ville de
toulouse secoué par une très violente
explosion
la déflagration survenue ce matin dans
une usine pétrochimique dans la
périphérie toulouse a fait au moins 18
morts et 650 blessés selon un bilan
encore provisoire
toute l'agglomération toulousaine a
ressenti un immense choc équivalent une
fausse couche de 3,4 sur l'échelle de
richter
devant l'ampleur de la catastrophe le
président de la république et lionel
jospin se sont rendus sur les lieux
cet après midi c'est la fin de ce 19e un
merci de l'avoir suivi le dernier rendez
vous avec la rédaction
le soir 3 ce soir aux alentours de 22h30
avec jean sébastien fernandez le sur
trois qui reviendra bien sûr longuement
sur tous ces événements excellente
soirée et à demain
bonsoir à toutes et à tous voici comme
tous les soirs les principaux titres de
l'actualité sportive que nous
développons dans quelques minutes
les basketteuses françaises que voici
qualifier brillamment pour la demi
finale des championnats d'europe
elles ont battu tous à l'heure la
slovaquie 72 à 56 c'est la 6e victoire
consécutive des françaises en coupe
davis et du tennis c'est bien parti pour
la france qui mène deux victoires à zéro
face au pays